was another bill soon to be passed here
in Tennessee which would outlaw sexual
performances for children primarily
Banning quote-unquote family-friendly
drag shows
and the reason that I say it would
primarily ban those is that drag queens
are the primary ones who are most eager
and insistent on performing in front of
kids which is all the more reason so
it's it's a little bit like if I said
that uh you know stealing is illegal and
that primarily affects kleptomaniacs
well it's not a bill that says only
kleptomaniacs can't steal but if you
have a compulsion to steal in a certain
way you might say that you're more
affected by that bill but that's because
of you that's a you problem it's your
own fault
oh
[Music]
[Applause]